[Music]
getting excited about the Olympics gonna
start the opening ceremony the opening
ceremonies on Friday and I guess it's
going to be very British yeah this is
the this is the latest this is true this
is true it leaked out that the London
Olympics Opening Ceremony is going to
include a showdown between Voldemort and
Mary Poppins Mary Poppins yeah the
winner then goes on to a battle to the
death with Thomas the Tank Engine and
then Paddington Bear I guess how is that
even going to work I don't know I by it
sounds interesting though I will watch
it yeah Voldemort Mary Poppins
take your nose away get to your room for
the more I'll get you married I haven't
done the dishes it's a very good
impression thank you I want to see a
little more Voldemort out of you from
now on today Michelle Obama said that
the Olympics can inspire American kids
to get active nice yeah or it can
inspire American kids to sit on the
couch and watch the Olympics eating
Doritos Locos Tacos I'm gonna keep
mentioning those till I get some for
free even though the Olympics take place
during Ramadan some Muslim athletes said
that they will not fast during the
London Olympics yeah not gonna do it
then after sampling the British food
they said you know on second thought
fasting one bite of eel and kidney pie
yeah that's a real food folks I didn't
make that up
it's very good now many people are
criticizing the London Olympics mascot
for being creepy because the mascot has
just one huge eye that looks like a
camera yeah and not helping is its
catchphrase I can see you on the toilet
why why would that be a ketika they do
with the Olympics t-shirts I find it
creepy well unfortunately some bad news
for the economy the poverty rate in the
u.s. is now at its highest since the
1960s ya know it's gotten so bad today
Mitt Romney's Butler had to let his
Butler go a strip club in Tampa is
luring Republicans with a Sarah Palin
look-alike yeah the woman is identical
to Sarah Palin in every way except the
stripper has a tangible skill
[Applause]
that's money that's the word stripper
man yeah
and she goes around around amber slowly
this is great last week at a Tony
Robbins seminar several people burn
their feet while walking over hot coals
yeah yeah but check this out now thanks
to the Tony Robbins seminar those people
feel empowered enough to sue Tony
Robbins I can get a lawyer a member of
Best Buy's Geek Squad is in trouble for
copying racy photos of a customer's
iPhone and inviting her to his home to
retrieve them yeah Best Buy has fired
him from the Geek Squad and hired him
for the perv Patrol
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in Oregon a man broke into three homes
and looked at porn on the computer you
there are three husbands in Oregon came
up with the exact same experience
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]